In this section, we will go over how to import a custom metahuman body skeletal mesh into
Unreal Engine and configure it.
If you wish to go through the steps, the custom body skeletal mesh is located in the source
files folder of our course in the custom body working export folder.
Now, let's jump back into Unreal Engine and go over the steps for importing a custom metahuman
body.
Right of Unreal Engine, I am going to go through the steps of importing the custom body FBX
file.
First, I will navigate to the body folder.
Next, I will go to import and in the export folder, I am going to select the Atomic-S
body export skin weights FBX file.
Since I used the interchange feature flags command earlier, the FBX import options window
will appear instead of the import content window.
In the FBX import options window, I am going to assign the metahuman base skeleton over
here.
Since the body FBX file was exported in YUP, I want to make sure the import rotation is
still set to 90 degrees.
And I also want to make sure that import animations is checked off.
Now I can select import.
I am going to save everything now.
Next, I am going to double click on the skeletal mesh to open it up.
Now, we want to assign a material to this.
So I will go back to the main viewport and select our metahuman in the level.
In the details panel, I will select the body component.
And then I will locate the material and navigate to it using this folder icon.
With this selected, I will return back to the skeletal mesh window.
In the asset details panel in the materials slot, I will assign the body material instance
to this.
Next, I will scroll all the way down here to locate the default animating rig.
I will assign the metahuman control rig for the body here.
I will use this drop down arrow and then locate it and select it.
If you have an animation blueprint that is set up with body correctives, I will show
you where you can assign that.
I will scroll back to the top of the asset details panel.
For the post process animation blueprint slot, I will use the drop down arrow and I will
select the animBP RBF correctives blueprint.
And if you wish to inspect this blueprint, you can find it in the course assets folder
in the atomic savage folder.
I will delve into this animation blueprint later, but for now it is worth noting that
it uses corrective poses that have been authored using the pose driver connect toolset.
Now let's do a quick review of the steps we just went through before we move on.
We just went over how to import a custom metahuman body into Unreal Engine.
In the import options, under the common section, we want to change the offset rotation to 90
degrees if the skeletal mesh is in Y up.
Next, we want to assign the metahuman base skeleton under the common skeletal meshes
and animation section.
And under the animation section, we want to ensure that import animations is checked
off and then we can select import.
Once the skeletal mesh has been imported, the next step is to configure it.
Inside of the skeletal mesh window, in the asset details panel, we can assign a material
to the body.
Then we want to assign the metahuman control rig for the default animating rig.
If you have authored corrective poses using the pose driver connect toolset and have created
an animation blueprint with those, you can assign that to the post process animation
blueprint slot under the skeletal mesh section.
Now the images on the top right demonstrate what the shoulder area looks like within without
corrective poses.
Once we have imported all of the modified assets and finalized our character, the last
step is to test the character by applying animations to it.
In the next section, we will test the face and body with animations and check to make
sure that everything is behaving correctly.